for some of the best Christmas displays
in the valley you might not have to
drive far with the help of the Las Vegas
Christmas light map Nanette malamad a
Vegas family guide is here with more on
this along with Caitlin and Sam thank
you all for being here today I love this
idea and you came up with it more than a
dozen years ago yeah so for about 12
years we've been doing it and it just
gets bigger every year it gets more and
more fun people do more lights
and it's everybody loves it so you
started it even before Caitlyn and Sam
were born you have an older child as
well I have a 13 year old okay so Vegas
family guide has been around since 2010
so there's always been some form of a
map and like I said it just keeps
getting bigger and bigger so where do
people go to find the map so you can go
to Vegas Christmas lights map.com okay
and there's a list of Area Homes and
then there's also a Google map so if you
pull up the Google Map it shows where
you are you can just start driving from
wherever you are in town and how do you
decide if someone makes the list
so homeowners send in their homes and
community members send it in and then
there's like some really big shows
around town so we probably have like 20
huge late shows different little
neighborhoods that well where there are
little neighborhoods and then we have
like people who do like huge light shows
in their yard and so we list those
separately so you know where to go for
the computerized shows and the big shows
um and then other people just send them
around and we put the pictures on the
map and you guys can decide where you
know what's best for you but a lot of
times it's just a tour you know you
start one place and then you just enjoy
the lights as you drive from house to
house so no matter where you live in the
valley there's probably something pretty
close definitely something in every area
of the valley so I can 100 certain tell
you there's a light show in every part
of town how fun and this has gained
popularity over the years obviously it
is it's a fun tradition you put the kids
in their pajamas grab some blankets and
some hot cocoa turn the Christmas music
on and just drive around town Caitlin
and Sam you guys get to do this every
year Sam what what's your favorite kind
of Christmas decoration
um probably like inflatable grinches oh
okay you even have the Grinch pajamas on
I like it a lot Caitlyn what about you
the same yeah I like those and do you
have favorites that you want to go see
every year
it's every year is like the Robindale
house you know and that's back this year
there's also three really big Grinch
houses in town with tons of Inflatables
and they love to see those
um and then Red Coach is back this year
up in the Northwest so if you could only
pick one oh God and I know that's
putting you on the spot but if you said
oh if you're only going to see one set
of decorations this year
where would we go oh that's so hard you
put me um I don't know if I can decide I
would say this year 440 kellsford and
Silverado Ranch combines the music the
Inflatables the lights and everything
but that I can't just pick one I know I
know that was unfair that's a really big
one that combines everything so one more
time so people can have their choice
where do they find the map Vegas
Christmas lightsmap.com or you can just
go to vegasfamilyguide.com what a great
idea Nanette thank you so much Sam
Caitlin you guys are awesome
have you ever been on TV before
you were amazing you were like this
professionals like you've done this a
million times
we will toss it over to Jillian